How many times have you
heard this classic tale?
Some sort of apocalypse wreaks havoc
on our planet and before you know it,
all the people are gone except for
this guy, the last man on earth,
he somehow manages to run
into the last woman on earth.
They decide that it's up to
them to save the human race.
So they start making babies and soon
enough the earth is repopulated and
everyone lives happily ever after.
But is that even possible?
What kind of awkward problems would be
involved and why would our new population
be so different?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
you had to repopulate the planet.
Repopulating and entire planet would
be no easy feat in this scenario.
Assuming the two remaining
people are actually for towel.
The first generation of
this new population would
all be brothers and sisters
and the second would be cousins.
If the world's new population
is just a product of inbreeding,
does it even stand a chance?
So our last couple on earth has as many
babies as they possibly can. That's fine,
but we can't stop there.
I mean that's nice for a family picnic,
but we're trying to
repopulate the world here.
Taking the next step means that all their
kids now have to have babies with each
other
in order to understand
just how deadly that is.
Let's have a little lesson in genetics.
We all have two copies of every gene,
one from each parent.
Some of these copies can be bad genes.
The carry genetic disorders carrying these
variants on their own isn't a problem
as long as we only have one copy.
In fact,
most people watching right now are
carrying one or two genetic variance that
could be deadly if we're born with
an identical pair of these variants,
that's when we run into trouble and
if our parents are brother and sister,
their genes are much more likely to be
similar as more and more relatives in
breed,
the chances of their offspring receiving
identical copies of bad genes and being
born disabled or diseased
keeps increasing.
That doesn't spell good news
for the future of humanity.
But if we have as many
children as possible,
odds are that some of them will
come out healthy, right? Sure.
But what happens when this inbreeding
continues over hundreds of years for that
answer, all we have to do is look
at the European royalty of the past.
For centuries,
European royal families would intermarry
to keep the power within their ranks
and that quickly led to problems.
Okay.
The biggest victim of this was Charles,
the second of Spain,
who after generations of interbreeding
had less genetic diversity than he would
have if his parents had been siblings.
As a result,
he was born with a slew of
physical and mental disabilities.
He couldn't walk until he was eight years
old and his impotence led to the end
of the very dynasty his ancestors
were trying to preserve. All right,
so we get it.
Interbreeding is bad,
but what if we introduced a couple
more people pull to help with the
repopulation with that work?
Not really because our small group
of people would become vulnerable to
something called the founder.
In a small isolated population,
obscure and harmful traits become common
because the founder population limits
the number of possible genetic
combinations, even if they survive.
All the other fun that a post
apocalyptic world has to offer.
Odds are that the founding members genes
would eventually combined to pass down
some sort of deadly condition to the
children and with medical care being a
thing of the past.
The new humanity would probably only
last a couple of generations, but hey,
don't give up hope yet because history
shows that several small groups of
survivors have managed to grow
and beat the odds of genetics.
Maybe it would be possible to
recover from the apocalypse.
What would our new society look like?
Maybe our entire planet would speak
the same language or have the same
government, but that's a
topic for another. What if.